i think it's just that we really love
our business we really love what we do
we really enjoy working together i'm
natalie potter and i'm laura potter and
we are the mother daughter duo behind
bliss and baker and artisan crispy treat
company today we're going to be making a
crispy voter ballot box to celebrate the
american right to vote i think that the
best way to make really good crispy
treat would be to use a lot of
marshmallow melting them slowly and
being creative by adding other
ingredients into it yeah i would say
definitely melting it slowly is
important because if the marshmallow
gets too hot once it cools down it's not
going to give that same like stretch and
that gooeyness that we all love in our
crispy treats so our brainstorming
process for all of our different flavors
and our upcoming limited edition flavors
is we just really think about what it is
that people already enjoy the flavors
and the flavor combinations that they
like already and then we work our
hardest to put that into crispy treat
form you know owning your own business
it's important to definitely read up on
the candidates and policies for tax
purposes regulations especially on a
local level we always try to really read
up on that and be educated on what's
going on and how we can help a lot of
those local elections are involving your
community the policies that are created
have a big impact on small businesses as
well as large businesses and we always
take that into consideration before we
cast our votes so if it's your first
time voting you may have to wait a
little bit that's okay it's going to be
worth it bring a snack maybe a crispy
treat and you're going to have fun so
enjoy the process so when you're going
to register to vote just make sure that
you will be 18 at the time of election
it's very easy to register to vote you
can register online if you're a student
a lot of the times you can register at
school my first voting experience was i
believe when i was probably 20 years old
and i had a full-time job and it was
probably the first time i realized when
i got my paycheck you know what you're
really paying for and it made me pay
more attention to it and i also worked
with some older people that guided me
that it's important to vote so that was
my first moving experience my first
voting experience was very exciting i
kept like telling all the volunteers
like this is my first time like i'm so
excited we actually went together
and we voted at the local level it
wasn't emotional but it was definitely
like this is a really big deal like i
feel educated about this like i feel my
vote counts this is part of my duty as
an american citizen and it was really
exciting both got our stickers and we
wore them proudly i love wearing the
stickers i love wearing the stickers the
sticker is good and then when you see
other people wear the sticker
we're on the same we're on the same page
here yeah it's it's definitely important
to us to be involved at the local level
with our community so we know what's
going on we know who our elected
officials are yeah i mean it's important
that as we grow as a company we know the
people around us we know what resources
we have and to be able to vote at the
local level is just as important as our
presidential elections because it's
what's affecting us day in and day out i
think it's a great opportunity that we
have and something that maybe we take
for granted but it's definitely
important as an american citizen to be a
voter and to vote in all elections and
be informed of what's going on and know
that your vote counts and you have a say
in how things are done so in order to
spell out vote and for the stars we use
fondant and we just use alphabet cutters
for the vote for the voting sign we just
use a white chocolate bar and we've kind
of come up with this fantastic metaphor
for this so the cereal is the people and
marshmallow is the policies of the
regulations that holds us together as
one but that was a little bit of a
stretch but we loved it
we hope that our crispy voter ballot box
inspires you to be a voter and to
participate in your local community and
reward yourself with a crispy treat oh
yes
[Music]
you